hallo ihr sprecher zurück
hallo nora leser hier ist lotte nicht
warum ich wollte etwas fragen es ist
wichtig ich kann dir leider nicht
weiterhelfen
ok danke
was ist los bei euch habt ihr ärger nein
es ist alles okay okay du sagst ich
möchte nicht darüber reden
sag mal vergessen du davon wenn die
küche übernehmen
wir zeigen die menschen bei dem was sie
lieben ihre freizeit und ihre hobbys
macht dein hobby zum beruf oder was
meinst du ja ich meine das wünscht sich
doch eigentlich jeder eine gute
ausbildung schafft auch freiräume zeit
für hobbys keine existenzängste
ausbilden kann spaß machen mit einer
guten ausbildung
hast du die wahl das ist die kernaussage
dass das könnte ich mir vorstellen
natürlich müssen wir an den details noch
ein bisschen arbeiten aber wer von alex
events würden uns sehr freuen denn ob
trick zu erhalten
ich denke ich bin
ja ich muss dich bring ich musste nicht
meine visitenkarte
sie kommen immer
so
niedrig und ich musste um 1 uhr zurück
vielen dank dass du mich gebracht hast
allein hätte ich den weg nicht gefunden
ich kann doch nicht zulassen dass unsere
potentielle geschäftspartnerin verloren
meinst du damit dass ich kann natürlich
noch nicht sagen
ich finde die idee gut aber ich muss als
rücksprache mit meinem chef
ja natürlich aber das sagt jetzt nicht
nur weil ganz kennen das bestimmt
ein cappuccino in malzbier ein affe
saturn oder fassbrause und cacau zu
bringen
ehrlichkeit ist die basis jeder
beziehung
das muss ausgerechnet die sagen ja aber
die rechteckige facebook von ich springe
auf ihn zurück ihr müsst miteinander
reden
gehst du gerade diese zuordnung durch
was willst du von einer hochzeitsfeier
oder glaubst du etwa park city ein
uneheliches kind